Let's talk a little bit about the Bayer filter on the sensor.
So in essence, a Bayer filter is nothing else but
different types of color filters that are above the photo diodes.
And most of the time you'll actually see two greens and a blue and
a red, so this would be the four region here, that represents one pixel.
Four another here, that represents another pixel, four here and so on.
Of course, depending on the convention of the Bayer filter used,
sometimes you might have two reds and a green and a,
a blue, and also two blues and a green and a red.
Depends again on it, but
knowing exactly what is the Bayer filter is essential because we need to
know this to have to compute and then, come up with a final image.
Basically what happens with the Bayer filter is each one of them let's only
a specific light through.
So when the light is hitting the red, basically, the blue and
green are prevented from going through.
Red goes through.
Same thing with green.
Just the green goes through.
Same thing with blue, only the bo, blue goes through.
So, in essence, we create three different patterns.
Of course the photo diodes then store the intensity for each and
every one of them.
But, this coding scheme,
pretty much let's us know which one of the bins is actually blue, green, or red.
Then of course it's the combination of these three channels that gives us
the final image, and this is the one that we need to then decode and
save for our final things.
One of the questions that's important is,
how is the raw input in a Bayer mosaic format converted to an image?
What's the process to be able to then get basically the RGB color values,
that is, the RGB as we have discussed when we
talked about the image processing pipeline, the three channels separated out?